rassemblement cet après midi devant
l'hôtel de ville de paris un
regroupement à l'appel des sympathisants
du mouvement 5h par ils protestent
contre la politique de la majorité
municipale revendication principale
l'absence de propreté dans les rues de
paris et à la saleté il ya le manque de
considération des administrés la voirie
l'aller les th n'importe comment sans
réglementation les vélos qui font
n'importe quoi
les piétons qui sont danger tout le
temps l année le mobilier volée et
surtout en plus remplacées par des trucs
et demi deux pays de merveilles arrière
bien bien commerçants associations
professionnelles politiques citoyens
tout le monde doit réagir sinon paris va
être saccagée défiguré et va perdre son
commerce
paris est devenue de plus en plus sales
paris et saccagé au niveau de travaux
n'importe où n'importe comment
on a fermé quais de seine hees a
accentué sa congestionné tout paris avec
la fermeture de la voie georges pompidou
qui fluidifier la circulation à paris et
bien c'est est peut-être l'une des plus
graves est mauvaise décision de la
mairie de paris